MARK MIRCHANDANI: Stephanie,
what are you doing?
STEPHANIE WONG: I'm manually
making a copy of my data
in case my database goes down.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You don't
need to do that by hand.
Here, let me show you how
to set up high availability.
STEPHANIE WONG: All right.
Thank goodness.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Let's take a quick look
at what happens with a highly
available configuration using
MySQL.
The primary instance
and failover replicas
are in two separate zones.
As updates are made to
the primary instance,
they're replicated
to the failover.
If the primary
instance goes down,
Cloud SQL will make sure
the failover is up-to-date,
and then promote it to
the primary instance.
This is what it looks like
when the failover happens.
Instead of manually making
any application changes,
Cloud SQL moves the
primary IP address over,
so the same database connection
information will work.
It looks a little
different for PostgreSQL,
but you still get
seamless failover.
STEPHANIE WONG: So not only does
Cloud SQL manage my database,
it can actually handle
my primary database
going down too?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: That's right.
Now that we've seen what
happens in the back end,
let's take a look
at how to set it up.
By going to the Cloud
SQL Instances page,
we can our currently
running databases.
Looking at Needs Failover,
you can click the Add button
under High Availability to set
up an automatically managed
replica.
We'll go ahead and call it
Needs Failover Failover,
and hit the Create button.
This will create the
failover for you.
Now, if we're going to
create a new database,
the first thing we
can do is choose
between MySQL or PostgreSQL So
we'll click on Create Instance.
We'll choose MySQL, which
is second generation.
And we're going to go
ahead and give it a name.
We'll call it MyNewDB.
Don't forget to secure it
with a secure root password.
Then, we'll go to the
high availability section,
and we'll make sure
binary logging--
this is for MySQL--
is checked off, and click
Create Failover Replica.
We'll go ahead and then
click the Create button,
and we're good to go.
Now, once these
failovers are created,
the other thing we're able
to do is test out a failover.
So if we actually go to one
that already has it set up,
click in on that, and
then go to the top right
where it says failover.
This will let you actually
execute a failover.
Now you can see how easy it
is to make your Cloud SQL
instances highly available.
STEPHANIE WONG: So if
the primary instance
is down due to being patched,
or for any other reason,
we have a replica set
up and ready to go.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Don't
forget to like, comment,
and subscribe for more great
Google Cloud Platform content.